foreign
Court rejects Bernie griner's appeal
meaning the basketball Stars conviction
and nine-year sentence is upheld Greiner
was arrested in February when she was
caught carrying Vape cartridges
containing cannabis oil out of the
Moscow airport she was charged with
attempting to smuggle illegal narcotics
into Russia while Greiner pled guilty to
the charges later testifying that she
did not intentionally bring an illegal
substance into the country where she
played basketball in the WNBA off-season
Greiner was sentenced to a shocking nine
years in prison in order to pay sixteen
thousand dollar fine on Tuesday a
Russian Court rejected griner's appeal
of the conviction she is now expected to
be sent to a penal Connelly putting
additional pressure on the United States
to negotiate her release the US was
previously in talks of a possible
prisoner swap trading Griner for Russian
arms dealer Victor bound President Joe
Biden and Russian President Vladimir
Putin are expected to both attend a
summit in Indonesia Asia Next month
President Biden said he would only speak
with Putin if it was to discuss
greiner's release
Terry I know none of us are experts in
in Russian law or attorneys but did you
get the sense that this appeal was more
for show than an actual appeal
you know there's no question from the
very beginning the consensus has been
that this was just for show you know
they don't really want to hear any
relevant evidence they are not
considering any relevant evidence the
only thing that they did do her
nine-year sentence was slightly reduced
they allowed each pre-trial day in
custody to decrease her sentence by 1.5
days so it's not clear exactly how many
days it'll be reduced but that did occur
but despite all of that the position has
been that you know she's been wrongfully
detained and they definitely don't want
to help her in any way at this point so
Julie what's next for Bernie Greiner and
uh this story as she seeks to be
released
so you talked about the penal colonies
which is what her next step would be
it's terrifying because these are
supposed to be incredibly clear
incredibly harsh climates we don't want
her to be there
um by any stretch and the question is
whether or not there's going to be
um some type of prisoner swap we know
this is political we know that very
likely Russia won't do anything until
after the elections
um and so look hope that at least
sometime next year that something will
happen that brings her home to her
family we all agree that this sentencing
is absolutely preposterous
any buys on this as it develops and see
what's next as uh you laid out for us
Julie for Brittany Greiner and Johnny
Depp is once again making legal
headlines after suing a professor who
accused him of plagiarism
deput musical collaborator Jeff Beck
filed suit against Bruce Jackson for the
claims Jackson a University of Buffalo
professor and folklore authors said Depp
and Beck took lyrics from his 1974 book
Jackson argues the book follow Missouri
prisoner slim Wilson saying the song
lyrics are taken from words Wilson said
in his book while making a toast this
summer Jackson told Rolling Stone
magazine that the pair quote rips
something off of him in a lawsuit filed
last week Depp and Beck claimed Jackson
holds no rights over a toast court
documents claim the song quote is an
original work of authorship and
creativity and not an original work of
authorship created by Jackson attorneys
Ben Shu and Camila Vasquez Who Rose to
fame representing Depp during his highly
publicized defamation trial are named as
attorneys to appear prohawk viche in the
case